welcome back to Bismol since the
California reparations task force this
week voted to approve recommendations on
how the state can compensate black
residents for historic discrimination
Governor Gavin Newsom let's praise the
title Falls but appears to be cooling on
its advised perhaps because it could
cost 1.2 million dollars per person this
debate is everywhere right now the
British Monarchy is faced repeated calls
for reparations for historic links to
the slave trade or BBC journalist Laura
trevelyn recently quit a job to campaign
for reparations having donated a hundred
thousand pounds herself to Grenada were
her family historically owned slave so
is this a form of historic Justice or is
it just divisive well I'm joined by a
member of the California reparations
task force Jovan Scott Lewis and Fox
News contributor and civil rights lawyer
Leo Terrell all right welcome to both of
you
um Joven um thank you let me ask you
about this because on the face of it
I've talked about this quite a lot
recently I don't understand how the pain
from historic sins gets Eve by banging a
load of cash to people now
almost all of whom will have not
suffered the original pain so explain to
me
sure thank you for having me so what
we're doing in California is we are
dealing with some of the more recent uh
experiences of discrimination beginning
with the period of Jim Crow here in the
state of California so what we call
these are really the lingering effects
of slavery
um and so we're not providing
reparations or recommending reparations
for slavery itself but for the ongoing
institutional and state-based harms that
the African-American Community has faced
but it's not only African Americans I
mean look slavery was an evil evil thing
nobody denies that but it's not just
African Americans who have suffered
historic sins and ills against them
where do you take the logic of this
argument does everybody does every
community in the world who has been
mistreated historically are they all
worthy of financial payment and if so
how is the world going to pay all this
stuff given we're already suffering a
global financial crisis
right that's a fair question so what
we're doing in California is we have
effectively calculated the economic
losses that the black community faced as
a result of State policies and so we're
effectively tracing you know the the
capital that this community lost over
the the past you know uh century and a
half of discriminatory you know State
policies and the argument is that we're
building a reparations proposal around
those direct losses in addition to that
we have you know dozens of policies and
programs that are helping to effectively
end the kind of discriminatory cycle
that African-Americans have faced in the
state who's going to pay the bill
well thankfully that's not the task
Force's job to figure out you know our
job was to create a methodology for
compensation for calculating those harms
and we're passing it along to the state
legislature I think the state has a
variety of options of how to pay for
this uh the state if it decides to pay
for it again we are recommending
compensation uh we have come up with
calculations for how compensations can
be arrived at but the state has a
variety of I think instruments and and
uh approaches to how to stretch out a
payment if they decide to do so all
right we bring in Leo Tara you'll be
waiting patiently your response to this
Leo
well you've done a great job of asking
the right questions first of all they
cannot prove any form of direct damage
at all I challenge him as a lawyer as a
civil rights lawyer Pierce here's the
situation they talk about
institutionalized racism where is it you
got black Mayors in this in this state
they talk about systemic racism where is
it where is the where's the white
Boogeyman that they're talking about
they cannot prove that people of color
black folks deserve 1.2 million dollars
does Kamala Harris need it does London
breed the mayor of San Francisco does
Karen bass who Barbara Lee who's a
congresswoman they can't show this
what's the real reason behind this peers
I'll tell you what it is in 2020 during
the summer of Rise you had a governor
named Gavin Newsom who wants to Pander
to Black Americans in California in
order to run for president and I will
submit to you that if such a bill was
even contemplated there would be a a
challenge to it because it violates
equal protection Clause is institutional
and it's racist and I would be the first
as a civil rights attorney to challenge
such a law last Point Gavin Newsom came
out a couple of days ago appears and
said he is not inclined to support
reparations in a cash payment all right
listen you've made some fiery points
back there so Joe Van I guess by my
overview has been about this issue are
we now in this country for example going
to seek some form of payment from
descendants of the Romans and the
Vikings for the marauding around Britain
and if not why not in other words what's
the difference really ideologically
behind what you're striving to achieve
for the African-American Community for
historic issues and and that and me
saying well I'm sure some of my
ancestors were mistreated by Romans and
Vikings I'd like a large check please
sure and and that's a fair question and
you know counter to your other guests
claim we have established the exact
record of harm
um what we're talking about is that
African-American Community as recent as
1973 here where I live in South Berkeley
was demolished a commercial District was
demolished to build a train station
you're talking about African-American
communities that were demolished to
build Highway systems so the record of
harm is clear it is direct and I really
do welcome your other guests to view the
interim report that we released last
summer which is a 500 page detailed
report of the specific and direct harms
that African-Americans in the state have
faced at the hands of State policy and
that's what we're after yeah but I would
say this there are other communities the
gay community of the world right have
all had discrimination from the state
right you could argue and you could
argue that's caused a lot of pain and
harm so do members of the gay community
globally are they entitled to take your
you didn't say right we were
discriminated against by States we want
money for it in other words where do you
end
sure where you end is with State
responsibility and so if those other
communities and any communities can
establish an actual record of State harm
that is intentional and what I'm saying
is that these harms were intentional
we're talking about redlining where
black communities were directly targeted
by state dispossession we got talking
about an exact record that has been
established and so if any Community can
establish a similar record then I
encourage them to make a claim this is
what we're talking about okay this is
not about a cultural issue this is about
a record of harms that the state should
be responsible I understand and you've
expressed yourself in a very simple way
and I appreciate you for joining the
show thank you and also to you Leo
Terrell thank you very much indeed to
both of you